In this problem, a wastewater treatment
plant uses an activated sludge process
following a primary clarifier. The plant
receives an average daily flow of 3 MGD
with an influent BOD5 concentration of
250 mg per liter and an influent
suspended solids concentration of 300 mg
per liter. The treatment process
consists of a primary clarifier that
removes 35% of the incoming BOD5 and 60%
of the suspended solids. An aerration
tank that follows the primary clarifier
and removes additional BOD5 and
suspended solids.
The combined treatment processes of the
primary clarifier and aeration tank
together remove
5,645 lbs per day of BOD5 and 7,55 lbs
per day of suspended solids. What is
most nearly the BOD5 removal efficiency
within the aerration
tank? So the first thing we can see in
this problem is recognize that we need
to find the BOD5 removal efficiency of
the aation
tank. This means that all of the
information provided about the suspended
solids can be
ignored. Let's find the answer to what
we're looking for in four steps.
So for step one, our goal is to find the
total BOD5 entering the
plant. To solve for this, we simply need
to multiply the average daily flow of 3
MGD times a conversion factor of
8.34 pounds per million gallon over mg
per
liter. and then multiply this times the
influent BOD5 concentration of 250 mg
per
[Music]
liter. And we can see that the total
BOD5 entering the plant is
6,255 pounds per day.
For step two, we need to find the BOD5
removed in only the primary
clarifier. So let's draw out this
process really
quickly. We can see that after the flow
enters the plant, it is first passing
through the primary
clarifier and next going into the aation
tank. After that, we are assuming that
there is still some amount of BOD5 left
after each treatment process. And as
noted in the problem statement, the
combined BOD5 removed from both the
primary clarifier and the aerration tank
is
5,645 lbs per
day. Now, the problem provides us with
the removal efficiency of the primary
clarifier. Since this is the first stage
of the treatment process, let's multiply
this value of
35% times the total BOD5 coming into the
plant. We can calculate a removal at
this stage of the treatment process of
2,189.25 pounds per day.
Now in step three, we want to find the
amount of BOD5 removed in the aeration
tank
alone. We can solve this easily since
the problem tells us how much BOD5 was
removed by the combined processes of
first the primary clarifier and next the
aeration
tank. And we just solved for the amount
of BOD5 removed in the primary clarifier
alone.
So let's just subtract the amount
removed by the primary clarifier from
the total amount of BOD5 removed to get
the amount removed by the aation tank
alone. And we can see that this gives us
an answer of
3,455.75 pounds per
day. Now finally in step
four we can calculate the efficiency of
the aerration tank.
We know the total amount removed by the
first process, the primary
clarifier. And now we know how much was
removed by the second process, the
aeration
tank. So we just need to determine how
much was present directly before the
aation tank process and then divide that
amount specifically removed by the
aerration tank by that number to get our
efficiency.
So the amount present directly before
the aeration tank can be found by
subtracting the total BOD5 going into
the plant minus the amount removed by
the primary clarifier
alone. Then leaving a variable of X for
the efficiency
of the aation
tank. We can see that what comes out on
the other side is going to be the amount
removed in the aeration tank alone which
we just calculated for in step
three. So if we solve for X, we can see
that we get an answer of about
85%. Which is the second of the answers
listed in the problem. So in summary,
this problem is pretty easy if you know
a few
things. First, you have to notice that
you are supposed to ignore the
information about the suspended solids
and focus on
BOD5. Next, you need to understand that
the treatment processes occur linearly,
one after the next. Finally, you do also
need to be aware of how to calculate
pounds per day from million gallons per
day and milligrams per liter using the
8.34 conversion factor. As mentioned a
few videos ago, this is a good
conversion factor to sort of have
memorized or at least know when you need
it and where to find it. So, if needed,
you can find it in chapter 6 of the
reference manual under the section
titled solids loading rate. And that's
all it takes to solve this problem.